that's all
let's go back to basics
london system
i mean i'm down two games already
this could be
this could be a bloodbath
are we gonna get the same structure no
he goes d6 obviously
okay should we go h3
no not
i had something similar against him with
reversed colors in the world rapids in
2016.
and there he sort of managed to to
outplay me so
this makes me a little bit worried
yeah probably shouldn't have allowed
this should go d5
i guess i'll go d5 i don't think it's
great but
didn't see what else to do bishop
don't like giving up the bishop
particularly and
also 92 or 91 knight f4
then i have to go bishop g3 probably
and didn't love it okay i'll take an h4
first he goes knight of six then i take
on c6
basically uh he has a stronger
stronger center and the bishop pair
but he has a significantly weaker king
so i think
like theoretically black is absolutely
fine or he
might even be a little bit better but i
have the hope that
in practice it might be a bit easier to
play white
so here i just want to go rook c1 and
then b3
to evacuate the long diagonal
and hopefully limiting the power of this
bishop on
g7 yeah here i
think to queen a4 i go knight a4
i mean i already put one knight on the
rim so why not another
and after c5
c5 was kind of happy to see though i
think i'll go queen of
queen d3 and then the idea is to go
knight f5 next
and with c5 he's obviously could cut off
the
um the queen from from f5 which means
that i
can that i can annoy him this way
uh rook d8 knight f5 c4 does that
work
it would be really annoying if it did 97
king of eight
and i take on c4 in some way suck a
piece he takes an e7
and how do i attack his king
i think the answer is that i probably
can't
okay so we got a roof d1 instead
if bishop d7 i believe i can't go knight
f5
yeah now i will do it because d6 is
hanging after c4
foreign
okay spending a lot of time that is good
but he
i know this from um
[Music]
from all sorts of world blitz
championships that
he he can play really well when short of
time
i did miss queen takes d6
bishop takes a4 there's queen a3 then
rook d1
queen b4 that doesn't seem to work but
take on c4 immediately
king 7 queen d6
it's really complicated
okay i have a way to i i see a way to at
least win some material
there so i'll take on these six and then
i'll go rook c5 and screen before
i have rookie five [ __ ] b6 bishop b5
um queen b5 i take on b5
rook d8 rook b8 king goes and
i have two pieces and three pawns uh
sorry a rook and three pawns for
two minor pieces or namely two bishops
so i should be doing great there
okay so we give a check
bishop v5
okay rook b5 you can try and be really
cute and go rook c8 here
but i just um i just would win
anyway i think just take a d8 and win
the a pawn somehow
and like
i guess he has some chances here but
four pawns just should be more than
enough
should i take a d7
it seems like a good technical solution
actually
exchange a few pieces and then with
four pawns against this bishop it should
be should be quite
easy
so we just exchanged a bunch of pawns
creates
passages on both both sides now that he
moves his bishop i push a4 versus bishop
again
h3 it's just going to be way too
much too much for him to to deal with
here
go if h4 take with the uh
he has to go a h4 to have any sort of
chance but i don't believe it's
it's close to enough g5 now
i have four pawns that i'm pushing that
is just way too much for him
we push g6 then we go b4
a5
then we have e5 as well
yeah this is just way too much
[Music]
okay okay
if i just made a draw in the last game
we'd be
would be even at this point but um
i guess it's um i'll take
the point for sure